joining us now though is the ranking
member of the house in telemedicine
Devin Nunez of California congressman
good to see you sir
all these GOP investigators starting
with Ratcliffe and people like Lindsey
Graham and people like yourself you are
saying that there are classified
documents that will expose the misuse
the knowing misuse of the steel bossy a
especially as it relates to the FISA
applications can you tell us more well
first I'll start with that we want all
this information out let me say in kind
of to two tranches of what we're looking
for number one there's what we call
information on Papadopoulos that we
believe is exculpatory that should have
been out there and that's let's set that
aside the other set is there is that
exculpatory evidence and what might not
so it's it rests at the FBI we've been
asking for it to be declassified so
that's really all I can say about it
it's just that it's exculpatory evidence
that should be provided to the American
public on the FISA application remember
you have Comey who has called this a
mosaic so commis mosaic he remember when
we came out with our memo that brought
forward the fact that they had used the
clinton paid for dossier the the dirt
opposition research and then they had
leaked that to press outlets and then
they picked up those press reports and
used it in the FISA application Comey
said oh no no is a it was a mosaic there
was so much more information there well
there is more information there that we
think is equally as bad as using
opposition research let me ask you this
is it true let's start with the first
FISA application that the bulk of
information was the steel dossier bought
and paid for by Hillary Clinton full of
Russian lies was that the bulk of the
FISA application yeah so it is the bulk
but remember what we believe the rest of
it is to fill that fills out commis
mosaic is actually the true definition
of the insurance policy so remember the
talk of the insurance policy
by struck and page on the text messages
we believe that insurance policy is not
just about investigating the Trump
campaign we believe it is to ensure that
they were able to get the the FISA
warrant on Carter page so that they go
in and look at all the emails in the
campaign so the Carter page is just
being used his constitutional it's not
it's a no small deal but they violated
his constitutional rights to get a
backdoor into all things Trump campaign
that would be the Trump transition and
that would be even the Trump presidency
correct sir it's horrible what they have
done to many Americans but but let me
let me just say this about this shine so
this is we've been living for three
years with the perverted fantasies of
Glenn Simpson and the Clinton campaign
talking about P tapes and you know
supposedly you know reporters were all
over Europe looking for these P tapes
and this is really gross stuff and and
you showed that clip of Biden out on the
campaign trail when you have Americans
that are out there saying I think that
Vladimir is controlling President Trump
we can't live for six to six more years
of this those people have been poisoned
by these by this by just the the the
fantasies of Glenn Simpson and the
Clinton campaign so at some point the
FBI and the fusion this fusion network
they intertwined okay
and they were working in conjunction
together on this and I think that's what
the US attorney Durham is supposed to
get to the bottom of okay is it true
that at the top of the FISA applications
as congressman Ratcliffe has said it
says in pretty big letters verified is
that part true well everything is
supposed to be verified and and one of
the things that John Solomon didn't get
a lot of coverage that he broke last
week that you just talked about about
this high-level State Department person
that who had met with Steele that's
questioned 'el questionable in and of
itself but what nobody's paying
attention to err is is that three years
went by but yet one meeting with
Christopher Steele a high-ranking
State Department official in October of
2016 weeks before they went to the FISA
Court you had more verification done by
that State Department official who said
wait a second the Russians don't even
have a consulate in Miami okay I know
remember I remember
yeah all right let me so when
Christopher Steele was questioned under
oath in Great Britain in that
interrogatory and he doesn't stand by
his own dossier says I have no idea of
any of it's true we know from the State
Department official Cadillac that and
she rightly warned everybody that this
was political because he had a he had a
due date he needed of South before
election day sounded desperate but
doesn't that render that document
unverifiable if he won't stand by it and
he's not and I don't know if any of its
true 50/50 raw intelligence so and
there's a that signed a FISA application
was signing on of something that they
couldn't possibly have verified correct
there's a whole lot of things that don't
make sense about this but one thing that
we do know now for sure because of this
this revelation is is that the FBI did
in fact know that that Christopher steel
was talking to people within the State
Department they knew that at least one
big part of it cuz it's supposedly that
money was being funneled through this
Russian consulate in Miami which doesn't
even exist so the FBI knew knew good and
well that still had a lot of problems
and all and I'll say something else
about the about about steel so you know
it's called the steel dossier it's
really just Clinton opposition research
I think once we get to the bottom of
this what we're gonna find is is that
steel had a very small role and actually
crafting this and I'll go back to what I
started with these really were the
perverted fantasies of Glenn Simpson
working with the Clinton campaign to say
what can we draw up here that we can
spread out lies to the American people
that we can feed into the FBI and lo and
behold let's get an investigation going
on the Trump campaign that's really what
happened here and commis acting cute
with the word smile we don't spy in the
FBI he just signed a warrant to spy on
the Trump campaign and Carter page
and you know I know he thinks that he's
a super Patriot and smarter than we
smelly Walmart people well let me ask is
is there any doubt in your mind that
those that signed that those FISA
applications knew darn well that that
information was false and unverifiable
the people behind that we're building
those FISA applications had to have
known the problems with steel okay and
now we know we actually have now
evidence right we have a smoking gun
because we have emails now according to
John Solomon's report when you when you
move past that for sure by the second
third and fourth renewal of this FISA I
mean that is a totally project one they
were warned twice
Bruce or aluminum and the State
Department official warned them but
believe me they knew in the first one
yes but it's but what's even worse is I
think more people become contaminated
when you look at the second third and
fourth this went on for the full year
imagine that as an American citizen out
there the government was listening to
your calls and reading your emails for a
year
scary stuff it's no that that's the end
of the country if we don't get it right
Thank You congressman